I asked her if she loves you.
Was that a yes?
I mean,
should I really answer him?
I'm hearing.
So I'm 24 and Stephanie if Berg I am 43 years old and if I could describe our
relationship,
it's fiery
rock,
paper,
scissors.
Oh my God.
Was that,
she's from Europe.
So how about you just you go rock.
Okay.
Just put your hand down.
Just leave it there.
Rock,
paper,
scissors.
Okay.
You go first.
Yeah.
Oh,
like any,
a couple of this digital world we met through social media specifically I g
Instagram.
You actually slid into my dms and uh,
you messaged me about my voice.
Well basically he liked few of my pictures.
I went home,
his profile and I got very interested and I started liking and I started like
watching his videos,
what he's doing and I've been really cards with his bus and the,
I just messaged him and I,
I told him that he had an amazing voice and we started talking like that.
I was like,
okay,
supermodel.
She looks fairly interesting.
Um,
I think we could get along.
And you're,
you're also slightly intimidating as well.
You still are actually,
I just look at that.
Me and a little bit,
no way.
Oh,
come on.
like a supermodel Swiss supermodel.
Like pictures of you naked.
I would describe our relationship as like,
like a volcano and just mount Vesuvius.
Just like they just boiling underneath a Saute Pan,
you know,
just we're paying for this medium rare steak.
Okay.
He's that good.
The pizza and I'm like the fire.
Yeah.
I mean it's super passionate.
It's super,
I don't know what,
I can't,
what I can say.
It's a green tabs.
Gosh.
Name.
So are y'all married?
Are you,
you friends,
are you friends with benefits?
Like what's the relationship?
This is a good question.
I actually,
so uh,
we actually had an argument and um,
where I stand is that I don't really know exactly and I kind of prefer it that
way.
Our relationship is like the perfect representation of like a digital postmodern
world where there are absolutely no labels,
no gender and no age or like anything to define what the hell we're experiencing
in this short amount of three months.
And if I could find a label to describe what the hell happened,
I would
be nearly impossible.
Here's my boyfriend.
No.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
he knows that anybody,
he doesn't want it.
But the thing is like,
I don't feel any word and I don't fear any problems,
like rewarding a relationship.
He fears this kind of things.
So far me,
this is like a normal thing.
This guy is my boyfriend.
Yes.
I want to see him when I have free time.
I don't want to see another one.
Well,
I'd like to go with the label this route.
I like to think that we're just doing what we're doing.
We're having fun doing it.
I think it's too soon to say whether we are boyfriend and girlfriend or not,
but I do.
I do enjoy the time we spend together and I think it's important to,
yeah,
it's very important.
I agree.
I know,
I know.
It's fine.
I know everything about that
to patient,
to be patient.
I've learned to be passionate,
to be passionate and
to listen to him.
He is sometimes he's depressed,
he's going in this dark place and I know that,
you know,
like sometimes you know,
you speak and you have to just let it out and look this,
you,
you feel also better.
Like it's,
it's important and it's important that he has somebody with who he can talk to.
And I told him that and I,
because I want to know him.
Like it's not that I want just to like hang out.
Yeah.
That's cool.
You know?
No,
I want to know him.
Like I want to know him really.
You know,
like also when he's sad or his piss off or whatever,
some older,
the what is making,
yeah,
yeah.
I love him.
Of course.
I think he's amazing.
His just other worldly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She loves here.
I think so.
It was a yes.
Was that a yes?
You know,
I'd already,
you can feel it anyway.
Yeah,
I can feel it.
Yeah.
So of course I love it.
Do you love her?
Damn.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I do in one particular way.
I mean,
I'm not even sure what love actually is within myself.
So maybe I got to figure that out before I start sending it out to other people.
I don't know.
I don't want to give you the wrong information.
Who knows if I'm right.
With that being said,
I do care for you a lot and I hope the best for you and I really support you
with everything that you do.
You know,
I get these episodes of like just complete hopelessness within myself.
It's for you to see something in someone as young as me and like to really just
believe in me and the way that you do is something that I don't think I've ever
experienced.
I don't want him to be depressed because he has so much in himself.
He's so talented and he has everything he could.
This is frustrating me so much because I want him to be happy and,
and yeah,
this is what I would,
I would say to him,
there is opportunity.
You are so talented.
You can't make it like really high here.
And if you'll make it here,
you will make it everywhere and you can because you are
like,
you'll have everything to do it.
Like,
I trust in you so much.
And this is not only me
for some reason it's,
I'm kind of resistant to believing these things.
I Dunno.
I need to,
I think I need to work on
a form of acceptance,
but you know,
I'm just,
for my whole life,
I'm just so used to negative responses and rejections or it becomes almost weird
to receive anything else.
And you know,
I almost long for rejection because that's all I know.
But to hear you believe in me so much,
I think you're slowly teaching me the language that
I'm starting to understand
and I really thank you for that.
And that's why I really care about you.
I think you're,
I think you're a beautiful person.
I think you're extremely unique and you're also also extremely talented.
But on top of that,
you believe in yourself like no other.
And that's something the rest of the world needs to learn.
And I think that's one of the big purposes that you have here to show people
that,
yeah,
I'm going to cry.
Oh my God.
But really
he got something special too.
And I think,
I think everyone's starting to see as well.